[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
notre invité aujourd'hui est une femme
de lettres écrivaine universitaire son
monde c'est donc la littérature
l'enseignement l'écriture mais avant de
gagner cette rive le chemin a été plutôt
sinueux ce destin l'a un peu forcée avec
une audace et même un petit côté rebelle
qui lui vient peut-être de ses grands
parents qui l'ont élevé en pays sérère
au sud ouest du sénégal son grand père
par exemple l'an née pêcher avec lui et
rabrouait tous ceux qui osent et lui
dire que la place d'une fille était plus
à la cuisine qu'à la pêche rebelle aussi
parce que l'école elle a voulu y aller
envers et contre tous il lui arrivait
même de piquer des livres dans la salle
des profs les livres aujourd'hui en plus
de les lire elle les écrit il lui est
aussi arrivé je crois de penser aux
journalistes on tien tien journalistes
qu'elle enquête aurait-elle mener quel
reportage aurait-elle tourné quelques
questions aurait-elle poser à celle
qu'elle est devenue et bien justement on
va lui demander tous la bienvenue dans
un monde un regard bienvenue fatou diop
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
ici au dunk tournon au sénat si vous
aviez eu fatou diop en face de vous qui
question y auriez vous poser mais je me
disais comment elle fait pour être ses
singles c'est ce que vous pensez vous
alors comment faites vous pour être
aussi cinglé je voulais pas ces
questions alors ben je sais pas j'ai
toujours rendez vous avec une gamine qui
restent à moi qui à présent et c'est
elle qui est plus libre qui a le cran
que l'adulte n'a pas et je disais juste
vous avez vous lu du journaliste ça fait
partie de vos projets oui mon grand rêve
depuis l'école primaire d'ailleurs
c'était journalistes ou instit je
voulais enseigner le français comme
l'instituteur que j'admirais et je
voulais aussi journaliste parce que je
résumais ça je vous raconter la vie des
femmes et puis les enfants qu'on
maltraite donc c'était ça mon obsession
ben parce que je ne savais même pas
encore à l'époque il y avait plusieurs
sortes de journée lison et puis j'ai
quand même puis à s'offrir un petit pour
ma passion parce que j'ai été faire un
petit reportage pour artères abda mac au
népal et puis alors finalement vous avez
donc choisi d'écrire d'écrire des livres
je vais quand même citer quelques-uns de
vos ouvrages pour les gens qui nous
écoutent la préférence nationale c'était
le premier en 2000 ans le ventre de
l'atlantique en 2003 énorme succès
celles qui attendent en 2010 de quoi
aimer vivre en 2021 et puis c'était
c'est marianne face aux faussaires en
2022 si on avait dit justement à cette
jeune ado de 13 ans qui se met à écrire
plus tard tu seras écrivain est ce qu'il
y aurait cru ou pas non parce que toutes
les personnes qui moi qui m'ont prédit
cela j'ai toujours réglé je n'ai jamais
pu le croire j'avais rencontré seydou
badjan qui a écrit sous l'orage et que
les maliens quand j'étais au sénégal et
puis comme il avait lu certaines données
ou un certains textes de poèmes il me
disait
ça donc et puis quand j'étais à
strasbourg aussi j'ai que j'ai toujours
plus quand j'en avais trop gelé
détruisez pour écrire autre chose donc
les amis me disaient toujours pourquoi
tu ne fais pas publiés je n'y crois
absolument pas j'ai publié par hasard
c'était un pari avec un ami j'ai montré
le texte est-ce que c'est aussi parce
que écrivain ce n'était pas un métier
dont lille dans laquelle vous viviez
s'était d'ailleurs pas tellement
l'écriture la tradition c'est plutôt une
tradition orale donc j'imagine trouvé
difficile à envisager oui mais
maintenant ça n'est pas meilleure pour
c'est un mode de vie c'est ma manière de
deux d'arranger le petit chaos intérieur
que je peux ressentir parfois c'est ma
manière de poser des question d'essayer
de comprendre le monde qui m'entoure
mais je ne me sens pas du tout
professionnelle écrivain c'est quelque
chose que je fais mais même si j'ai
enseigné si je faisais autre chose mais
j'ai créé quand même c'est un besoin
dans ma vie et que c'est une seconde
nature c'est une nécessité vous savez
quand j'ai commencé j'étais au village
et je ne savais pas du tout que ça
pouvait être un métier déjà pour moi le
nom d'un écrivain c'était les noms qu'il
y avait à la fin des points encore
hésiter c'était forcément notre mort
c'était des anciens des antiquités ont
récité leur texte et c'est est
inatteignable ce n'était pas du tout
dans mon univers j'écrivais juste parce
que j'aimais ça et quand je suis parti
en ville pour le collège là j'ai
commencé à écrire beaucoup plus
fréquemment de manière plus soutenue et
plus je les ai plus j'ai connu plus je
lisais mais juste parce que ça me
plaisait encore aujourd'hui c'est comme
ça qu'est ce qu'elle écrivait cette
petite fille elle pas un journal intime
c'était des énormités que je n'osais pas
dire parfois de voir les adultes des
questions que je n'osais pas posé pas
forcé de non plus et puis des critiques
parfois
des choses qui me semble et
révoltante parfois et je ne savais pas
comment ni pourquoi
mais il y avait un sentiment diffus de
quelque chose que je ne veux pas ou que
je ne comprends pas et là j'ai crevé
j'ai couvert tout le temps comme on
entretient un dialogue on va revenir sur
votre parcours parce qu'il est
absolument incroyable peut-être d'abord
les conditions de votre naissance
puisque ça a quand même été déterminant
pour la suite vous êtes nés hors mariage
d'un amour d'adolescent et vous avez été
considéré comme un enfant du péché oui
on vous appelez même la bâtarde j'adore
ça a été une première expérience du
rejet dans votre pays oui parce qu'il ya
des gens qui sont absolument et cultive
ne peuvent pas savoir ce que c'est que
l'amour donc moi je suis la fille d'anna
moore totale libre volontaires décidés
pas de d'autres pas de mariage forcé qui
dit mieux je suis la fille de la moutte
hauteur et donc j'ai toujours été libre
mes grands-parents m'ont accueilli moi
accepter moins respectés et grâce à eux
j'avais toujours la tête haute donc
quand les gens m'insultent et oui il
m'avait raconté toutes les histoires de
ce village donc ma bouche c'était ma
maîtresse oui parce que les traditions
ray même voulu qu'on vous étouffe à la
naissance il faisait ça dans le passé il
ya plein de compte qui parle de ça il ya
même en compte qui parle des dauphins
qui récupère et adopte des enfants dont
personne ne veut et dans la tradition
contre la revenait tout le temps tout le
temps et vous savez la mythologie a
toujours quelque chose à voir avec
l'histoire réelle des peuples et c'est
un peu plus marrant donc on disait les
dauphins adopter les enfants deux nuls
vous voulez mais on disait que l'enfant
est mort-né donc l'enfant est mort-né
mailhac une matrone qu'il a vu et sa
maman qui est coupable de l'avoir eu
donc finalement ce n'était pas crédible
et comme j'étais elle veut pas des
grands parents mais ils m'ont raconté
tout ça oui parce que c'est pas des
dauphins qui vous récupérez des trains
dans l'est avait décidé de vous faire
vivre qui va même vous allaitez oui
quant à votre mère celle que vous
appelez l'autre dame vous allez avoir
une relation grande soeur avec elle
finalement vous allez être plus
indépendante qu'elle oui oui parce que
moi j'ai lu simone de beauvoir m non moi
j'étais l'école j'étais à la fac elles
n'ont du coup quand j'ai eu
on va des retours de 23 ans quand moi
même j'ai eu mes histoires d'amour j'ai
mieux compris cette femme et donc elle
est devenue un pour ma soeur mais
j'étais presque dans le rôle de la
grande soeur protectrice parce que
j'avais le kilo qu'elle n'avait pas mais
tout simplement parce que je connaissais
mes droits encore mieux qu'elle est là
avec la société traditionnelle qu'elle
acceptait moi j'étais déjà sorti de là
vous avez parlé de mon compère on y voit
les gens lisaient le film ne va pas la
pêche je disais pourquoi il finirait pas
à la pêche alors qu'une fille mange du
poisson parce que votre mère est ce
qu'elle est un peu aussi à l'origine de
ce féminisme de cette soif
d'indépendance que vous avez ce qu'elle
est l'exemple type de la femme que vous
n'auriez pas voulu être exactement lé
jeudi j'écris pour dire et faire pour ce
que ma mère n'aurait pas osé dire fr
donc elle est l ema mon portrait a
contrario il me suffisait de l'argade ii
pour me dire je ne vaux pas avec vous
comme ça donc je ne veux pas rester là
comme elle et ma grand-mère et c'est ça
qui prend donc ça parce que les anciens
étaient beaucoup plus ouvert plus libre
plus déterminés qui me poussait pourtant
20 c et les de la mésange gardien que je
les appelle ce sont mes grands parents
maternels ils avaient peur de mourir
avant mes 20 ans donc il met du quai
mais une espèce de d'intensité dans
l'éducation il fallait être autonome
avant le départ mais finalement j'ai eu
la chance d'avoir ma grand mère jusqu'à
42 ans et mon grand-père il est parti
quand j'avais 33 ans et ce grand père il
est peut-être aussi à l'origine de votre
féminisme je le disais en introduction
il voulait un peu dit c'est lui qui
disait tout le monde si si je l'emmène
pêcher avec moi on n'est pas forcément
la place d'une fille à la cuisine elle
peut aussi être à la pêche oui parce que
lui il était encore lee attaché aux
traditions sérères gallois rampe et
ignominieux il disait toujours chez nous
quand on dit le prénom d'un nom et le
prénom de sa mère parce que chez nous ce
sont des lignes à très linéaire donc
comme cet homme a un respect une
adoration pour sa propre mère pour lui
une fille ce n'est pas moins qu'un
garçon comme les religions le le suppose
pour lui une femme c'est l'origine de la
ligne une fille quand quand une fille
née c'est dans nos familles on faisait
une célébration plus importante que pour
les garçons allez monsieur serrano
fait rare et célébrer les flux dans
votre force dans votre histoire il ya eu
aussi cette envie irrépressible d'aller
à l'école et d'apprendre le français je
crois que vous alliez à l'école en
cachette un moment donné que c'est un
instituteur qui va convaincre votre
grand mère qu'il faut absolument que
vous y alliez ce qui m'amène à vous
parler de cette figure de l'enseignant
elle a été importante aussi dans votre
parcours oui même maintenant quand
j'écris j'ai toujours eu ce besoin de
faire une espèce d'incartades pour un
hommage au professeur ce n'est pas du
tout de la flagornerie c'est juste que
parfois j'ai encore des ports
rétrospective à l'idée d'être
analphabète
et donc quand j'écris de temps en temps
mais maintenant il m'arrive de m'arrêter
de moody wars écossaise les professeurs
c'étaient les magiciens donc l'école
primaire est en face de la maison de mes
grands parents et j'avais mes copines
qui partait à l'école qui chantait à la
clairefontaine
donc je savais chanter tout ça sans
savoir ce que je racontais cne et je
pouvais compter jusqu'à 100 sans pouvoir
parler français comme ceux qui étaient à
l'école alors j'ai voulu les suivre et
comme je n'étais pas inscrits
l'instituteur ou renvoyer quand tu es
rentré je revenais de prix vient se
placer ma commère et je continue quand
même et le jardin de ma grand-mère était
derrière l'école donc quand je
l'accompagnais dès qu'elle s'occupait de
ses légumes là je m'échappe et je
prenais mon abri créée puis je repartais
et vous avez des anecdotes incroyables
avec ses enseignants
c'est un instituteur qui vous fait
découvrir le sens de votre nom de
famille diom qui vont dire dignité et
vous dites c'est à ce moment là que vous
avez même retrouver votre dignité vous
la bataille pour me disent oui
mademoiselle dignité quand on est né
hors mariage dans un village musulman
donc où vous devenez libre où vous
devenez le larbin de services quoi et
cet enseignant vous voyez mon battre
donc évidemment vous l'éducation au
projet avec mon grand père mao qui
viennent d'être soleil donc elle à la
création c'est lé coup de poing je vous
dis et donc l'enseignant il venait
toujours me prendre par la main ils me
disaient mais arrête de te battre et tu
dis tu te débrouilles bien donc avec un
peu d'effort tout sauf de ce panier de
crabes thonon ça veut dire dignité et
pour tous le bien au lieu de se battre
et l adolescence vous allez quitter vos
grands parents vous allez faire vos
études à travers plusieurs villes du
sénégal et vos études vous allez les
financer en faisant des petits boulots
et j'ai lu notamment que vous aviez été
servante c'est ce mot que j'ai lu c'est
le mot juste cerveau à la touffeur les
gens aiment les au fémur une bonne à
tout faire c'est une domestique elle
lave la vaisselle elle fait est ce la
retirer céline est une espèce de regard
on peut sur la l'ironie de l'existence
elle pourrait être due elle peut être
belle
l'endurance aussi la patience donc la
persévérance pour moi c'est une vertu
calton et persévérant pour traverser les
bras de mer et débouler sur l'océan
c'est mon grand père qui disait et quand
la houle connu la barque il ya une chose
à faire c'est se mettre en action et
donc moi je voulais aller à l'école j'ai
mes grands parents je ne manquais de
rien par contre dans la vie paysanne
c'est la liquidité financière qui fait
un problème et donc pendant les vacances
d'été j'allais toujours en ville pour
gagner de trois mois de salaire et donc
à la rentrée ça me permettait de payer
mon inscription mais fournit dur et puis
l'on peu d'argent de poche à 22 ans vous
tomber amoureuse d'un français que vous
n'en français tombe amoureux de moi ou
le voilà le français tombe amoureux de
vous en tout cas c'est vous qui décidez
de le suivre à strasbourg et là aussi
vous allez faire l'expérience à nouveau
du rejet mais cette fois du rejet non
pas de votre belle famille si vous
n'avez pas l'expression belle famille
monique valaize moche famille
mais en tout cas de la famille de votre
mari là aussi une expérience douloureuse
chine pinailleuse français très secret
je ne vais pas suivi nous avons décidé
d'un commun accord et les martyrs et de
mettre notre domicile conjugal à
strasbourg il y est né donc je dis
toujours je suis parent immigré parce
que quand une parisienne se marie avec
un berlinois ou un canadien et puis elle
fait ses valises et puis le parrain
rejoint son domicile conjugal c'est
valable aussi pour les filles du
tiers-monde donc j'ai juste rejoint en
2006 le projet des halles parce que les
garçons ne l'était vraiment déterminé
oui et il a traversé l'atlantique et
encore et encore et le stand afrique et
puis donc quand on vous dit que vous m
avec cette détermination là si vous
n'êtes pas du pollen un moment donné
vous fondez et puis comme je le dis
toujours les plus beaux yeux de france
et vous ai dit aussi qu'on ne vous aimez
pas en tout cas cette famille vous ai
dit qu'elle nous venons aimé la blanche
neige c'est pas moi donc moi je suis
arrivé avec mon chocolat et puis c'était
une famille vraiment raciste
comment ça se manifeste pas noir dans la
famille vole pas de petits métiers savez
quand il ya un mariage on invite tout le
monde il faut pas venir avec la
sénégalaise quand il ya défaite et ben
tu viens monsieur mais tu laisses la
derrière donc voilà
et ce n'est pas grave j'ai étudié ont
changé à plus autre chose j'ai découvert
une partie de la nature humaine et je
les plans et je continue à penser que
c'est un homme bien parce que sinon je
ne l'aurais pas imposer il était
fantastique
on sent votre place mais fantastique on
sent votre force mais est ce que quand
même vous dire est que vous avez été
victime de racisme ou le mot victime
vous dérange
j'ai subi durera 6 oui et je ne suis pas
victime parce que je ne suis pas couché
pour l'admettre donc ce que vous vous
défendez vous n'êtes pas dans le profil
de la victime noire ou rejettent jérôme
rothen je regarde ma vie isolation le
musée s'est barré j'ai fait femme de
ménage en alsace pendant huit ans
donc quand vous faites femme de ménage
vous ne le faites pas pour buzz pour
courber l'échiné vous faites votre
ménage pour ne rien demander à personne
mais savez vous savez aussi sur nos
victimes parce que pour mais aussi les
mots sont importants et je sais que
c'est un mot qui vous dérange puisque
c'est aussi ce côté
si mr dans les mouvements antiracistes
qui vous dérange c'est qu'il se pose en
victime
la boe c'est soyez résolus à ne plus
servir et vous voilà libres
donc nous sommes nés avec un sentiment
de liberté que nous pouvons défendre le
sentiment de victimes on peut aussi
grandir avec ça dépend comme on l'a été
éduqué vous savez ces mouvements je les
comprends mais je comprends aussi la
chance que j'ai eue d'avoir les grands
parents qui m'ont élevé qui était
vraiment mon grand père était un homme
droit comme ça et en fait son modèle
d'homme c'est mon premier capitaine mais
au sens large du terme c'est un exemple
mon grand père il m'en voudrais si je
m'écroulais là en disant oui au cupidon
s'est barré je ne sais pas quoi faire et
puis je pleurais je puis la france un
tiers monde est animé les jérémiades
votre grand-père plénier de la chaleur
ils vous disaient tu crois que tu es
pleurs vont nous ramener plus vite au
village al-ram voilà ramer plus vite
toujours plus vite on arrive au village
et ses cantons mon ex mari s'est barré
enfin séparé pendant
que d'aimer les mots vous avez bien
moins littéraire
donc quand il est parti mon grand père
m'a dit tout simplement si tu es capable
de lutter la bagarre d'état dignité qui
vont continuer des études de phase i
maintenant si tu dois te comporter la
base d'une manière que je n'ai plus
n'aurait pas pu admettre ici au sénégal
tu fais tes bagages dû rentrer à la
maison on ne manque pas de quoi nourrir
et puis à la maison et tu sais où dormir
donc tu décidé alors j'ai décidé de
poursuivre mes études parce qu'elle me
disais que tu sois il faudra débattre si
j'étais rentré au sénégal il aurait
aussi fallu continuer mes études mon
bateau pour ça la météo c'est ce qu'on
entend chez vous tout de même ces
mouvements antiracistes qui eux parlent
de rejet et ses mots qui reviennent
homme blanc blanchi thé blanc et non
blancs racisées vous qui aimez à ce
point les mots qu'est ce que ça vous
fait qu'est ce que ça vous inspire de
les entendre comme ça qu'il ya un mépris
hérités de l'histoire coloniale qui
reste et donc ça pour blesser les gens
je le comprends il ya les séquelles du
colonialisme
il a pu blesser les gens je les
comprends ils se révoltent contre ça il
ya le déséquilibre économique mondial
aujourd'hui qui fait que les pays
africains ne se sentent pas vraiment
suffisamment respecté donc
le concert des nations je comprends tout
cette révolte là mais je ne comprends
pas l'idée que quelqu'un puisse vivre sa
vie pour être juste contre contre contre
moi et je lutte pour
joly pour un dialogue je lutte pour une
entente on peut solder cette histoire
coloniale il faut en parler on peut
faire des débats des passionnés tout
simplement mettre une dialectique de la
compréhension de ce qui nous est arrivé
ensemble et comment nous pouvons
dépasser cela donc maintenant si
quelqu'un pense que au palais de
l'esclavagé la colonisation c'est une
fonction vitale maintenant je suis
désolé pour cette personne là pascal
martin luther king nous disait bien
notre soif de liberté ne doit pas nous
pousser à boire la coupe de l'amertume
et de la haine donc je préfère écouter
ces mots là et elle sonne n'est pas que
c'était encore plus dur en tant que noir
se plaint de l'amérique et lui il a été
capable de dire cela et je préfère les
gens qui se réconcilier avec l'histoire
les gens qui avancent les gens qui
savent aussi que l'histoire humaine et
toute l'histoire humaine je ne parle pas
de noir et blanc elle est faite de
domination libération de conciliation
vous êtes une spécialiste du xviiie
siècle le siècle des lumières est ce que
la france d'aujourd'hui
tourne le dos à la france des lumières
ou est-ce qu'elle ressemble à cette
france que vous avez aimé dont vous êtes
même peut-être tombe amoureuse à la
france ne tournera jamais le dos
l'esprit des lumières le panther est là
pour nous le rappeler
donc toutes les rues de france nous
parle de la lumière du xviiie même le
soleil de ce matin nous parle de la
lumière
donc ce sont des gens
expressément qu'ils décident eux de se
détourner de la lumière pour rentrer
dans les fourrés avec les loups ce sont
eux les perdants moi je pense que la
france en tant que telle ne peut pas se
départir de son héritage des lumières
j'ai une photo à vous montrer c'est une
archive qui nous a été transmise par les
archives nationales qui sont nos
partenaires jouent là je vous la donne
vous allez probablement reconnaître
et oui on peut y voir léopold sédar
senghor avec andré malraux deux hommes
politiques d'envergure deux hommes de
lettres aussi là était premier président
de la république du sénégal première
africains à siéger à l'académie
française l'autre ministre d'état grand
écrivain on est là sur cette photo en
avril 66 lors du premier festival
mondial des arts à dakar est ce
qu'est ce qu'elle symbolise pour vous
cette photo est ce qu'elle symbolise un
lien particulier quand même entre la
france et le sénégal que l'intelligence
et sans frontières et que chaque fois
que vous mettez deux personnes qui ont
de la matière grise un choeur propres
ils ont de belles choses à se dire est
qu'il ne pensons même pas leurs couleurs
donc parce que la matière grise je pense
que ça a la même
année c'est sûr je pense à et donc et
ces deux là ont des choses à partager de
la culture de l'histoire de la beauté du
monde il était passionné par les arts
tous les deux par les civilisations et
ce sont surtout deux érudits qui sont là
ensemble mais honnêtement quand ils sont
là parler du destin de l'humanité ils
ont vraiment autre chose à faire que
mesuré des taux de mélanine est ce qu il
fait rêver la france au sénégal
aujourd'hui est ce que quand on est
sénégalais jeunes sénégalais aujourd'hui
on envie d'aller faire ses études en
france ou pas ou c'est fini elle faisait
plus rêver en tout cas avant mon arrivée
je ne veux vexer personne mais après
votre ministère de l'immigration et de
l'identité nationale
et puis les invitation à quitter le
territoire français
donc il ya une certaine politique
d'amélioration moment du monde nicolas
sarkozy entre l'utile à gaz que j'ai vu
d'après ce que j'ai vu en allant de
l'afrique que je voyage beaucoup en
afrique les gens et fx et du traitement
était infligée aux étrangers ici et
notamment aux africains dont qui
j'allais vraiment il faut vraiment que
l'on fasse attention nos leaders ici il
faudrait que je fasse attention à leur
manière de parler des étrangers d'une
manière générale aux politiques
d'immigration tout ça tout cela a des
répercussions en afrique et en plus plus
qu'on ne l'imaginé c'était les gens
regardent la télé lisent les journaux
internet maintenant a applaudi les
frontières donc les gens sont au courant
donc évidemment quand on entend certains
discussions les immigrés les immigrés
les musulmans les résumé mais vous
perdez le goût l'admiration toute cette
rêverie qui accompagné le mot france
commence à s'éroder et il faudrait faire
attention à cela mais ce que d'autres
sont en train de prendre la place de
laura française je pense aux chinois je
pense aux russes aussi est ce que on est
en train de regarder ailleurs maintenant
non sur tout le continent africain est
peut-être en particulier au sénégal je
ne dis même pas que les autres sont en
train de prendre la place de la france
est ou non ce sont les africains qui
s'autorisent à regarder ailleurs donc
vous savez si vous faites des
déclarations d'amour à quelqu'un qui n'a
rien à faire à moins d'être maso vous
changer de regard vous cherchez ailleurs
l'afrique n'a aucun intérêt à garder ces
matières premières pour elle toute seule
en les vendant elle peut se développer
mais l'europe doit arrêter de payer leur
jeu sénégal par exemple le tarif fromage
suisse
il faut payer les matières premières aux
prix que ça mérite et on n'aura plus
besoin de cette aide humanitaire qu'ils
nous humilient on continue avec d'autres
photos si vous voulez bien cet idiome
alors j'en ai une autre
celle ci peut vous le reconnaissez
j'imagine ce momen beau gars art roman
six sénégalais prix goncourt 2021 auteur
de la plus secrète mémoire des hommes il
est une première écrivains d'afrique
subsaharienne à obtenir cette récompense
mais lorsqu'il a reçu ce prix il a dit
ceci l'académie goncourt envoie un
signal intéressant important à tout
l'espace francophone notamment à
l'afrique on renoue avec une tradition
bien française d'accueil d'écrivains qui
viennent de l'espace francophone comment
si vous êtes d'accord avec lui
ça a été un symbole fort ça a été vécu
comme ça là pour le coup sénégal je
n'étais pas encore au sénégal depuis que
ça s'est passé je terminais mon livre je
trouve que c'est toujours assez
d'ouverture qui est toujours
encourageant encore une culture regarde
vers d'autres cultures donc pour ma
sélection de positif en plus et puis le
c'est un jeu non donc pour moi c'est un
encouragement à la fois pour les pays
africains pour les étudiants africains
mais aussi pour les étudiants ici en or
pour les étudiants français oui c'est
possible avec du travail avec de la
patience est possible de rentrer dans
des métiers d'art dans la littérature et
d'y trouver son chemin donc je pense que
c'est positif et la langue française est
encore toujours bien sa place au sénégal
l est
bien écrite bien parler où elle
disparaît la tendance à disparaître vous
savez les gens qui vous corrige plus
facilement ce sont des africains qui
regarde parce que nous on a une
apprentissage livresque donc il ya une
série dramatique à l'est puis le
français est une langue très coquette
très élégante avec ses subtilités comme
ça et puis il faut faire attention à
tout ça quand on est rangé qu'on a
appris cette langue depuis l'extérieur
on fait attention donc les aînés par
exemple qui ont étudié à l'époque de
senghor pour moi c'est le meilleur
français que j'attende ils sont
incroyables avec la précision
linguistique stylistique le lexique
n'est jamais ce truc choisi au hasard et
je pense que cette langue comme di lena
kateb yacine sene notre butin de guerre
donc sa manière d'arriver dans nos pays
c'était violent certes mais aujourd'hui
cette langue est devenue une des langues
africaines en tout cas pour moi c'est
une des langues africaines qui nous
permet de communiquer entre nous quand
je rencontre d'autres africains de côte
d'ivoire du burkina du mali quand je ne
parle pas leur langue ni eu la mienne on
utilise le français donc pour moi c'est
une langue qui nous permet de dialoguer
de fraterniser rossé l'afrique est un
tout petit peu modifié français ou pas
avec des mélanges qui peuvent un peu
j'imagine vous agacé vous qui êtes une
fune puristes de la langue française ou
la modifier cette langue mais des épices
du piment exemple ah oui oui par exemple
les expressions moi je suis obligé
parfois d'en fabriquer donc si je vous
dis ici ça me fait chaud au coeur en
france ça renvoie une impression de
bonheur d'accord bon ce qui fait froid
évidemment en alsace avoir chaud au
coeur on peut penser à chocolat chaud au
sénégal si vous dites ça me fait chaud
au coeur oui ça veut dire ça mais ça me
met en colère d'accord et bien parce
qu'il fait très chaud chez nous dont
quelque chose qui agréable pour nous ça
nous rafraîchit le coeur donc dû au
magic rien dans mes romans pourra
envoyer une telle expression oui je suis
obligé d'en que y ait une pour qu'elles
soient intelligibles des deux côtés mais
apparaissent en voilà une autre photo et
ernest hemingway
l'écrivain américain auteur du livre le
vieil homme et la mer en 1952 vous savez
très bien pourquoi je vous le mans reste
un auteur majeur pour vous vous avez dit
un jour il est mon grand père quand tes
lectures elle pourquoi parce que sa
manière de regarder la condition humaine
est précisément celle des pêcheurs cette
lutte face aux éléments face à la nature
cette lutte pour son pain qui doit
sortir des flots donc manger lui le
vieil homme et la mer j'étais au collège
et j'ai eu l'impression de voir mon
grand père à chaque page et donc peser
les ramener au village pour essayer de
traduire
parce que mon grand-père ne connaissais
pas ce texte lui lisait la rapée de
traduction en europe aussi mais quand
j'ai lu ce texte je les amenais on en a
parlé je lui en parler et le musée il a
fait ça et la pirogue et le respect dont
il ne vais pas le sentais donc voilà
raconte et à chaque fois j'avais
l'impression que mon grand-père le
visage de mon grand-père se superposer
aux personnages dans le livret et c'est
pour ça que je lui ai rendu hommage dans
le vieil homme sur la barque parce que
lui c'est le vieil homme et la mer et
bien moi j'ai vu le vieil homme juste
moi qui étais sur la barre c'était mon
grand père et j'ai rendu hommage aux
deux dans ce texte une dernière photo
fatou diome ce que vous reconnaissez
le vox
annonce à nouveau que ce doux c'est à
strasbourg c'est votre vie
vous avez dit un jour les villes ce sont
des visages ce sont les gens qui nous
accueille et nous aide à nous sentir
bien est-ce que les visages de
strasbourg vous ont aidé à vous sentir
bien oui dès que je pense strasbourg je
vois des noms des visages mais une liste
de personnes comme ça à chaque fois
parce que quand je rentre enfin après un
voyage quand je reviens ce sont les
visages là qui me reviennent parce que
je sais bien j'ai rendez vous avec une
telle ou telle copine et puis tel grand
frère depuis et j'ai des amis comme ça
où je sais que quand je reviens c'est
comme quand on rentre dans sa famille en
quelque sorte c'est ma famille
européenne et j'aime la même chose en
allemagne aussi ma famille en france
elle est à strasbourg et puis à paris
j'ai ma tata dans le xviiie
arrondissement
donc je vous dis pas où mais là
je les brosse et puis à collonges et mes
amis allemands et je sais que quand je
pense l'allemagne je pense colonnes
beaucoup de gens vont au palais de
berlin parce que ces immenses et qu'on
paris et ben moi ma famille allemande et
les et vous possèdez visage plus que des
monuments oui où elle apparaît bruxelles
pareil pour zurich est partout alors
vous avez votre petite famille et des
visages qui font cette ville une
dernière question qui est en lien avec
ce lieu fait où dieu nous sommes
entourés de quatre statues et n'ont pas
pu vous échapper son bel immense mais
elles représentent chacune une vertu
vous avez derrière vous la sagesse ici
la prudence ici la justice est derrière
moi l'éloquence à laquelle de ces vertus
vous vous identifiez le plus laquelle
vous parle le plus peut-être
sagesse prudence justice éloquence
je n'ai pas la sagesse peut-être comme
un sale temps ça viendra ou pas ouais
une partie de la lâcheté viennent de
trop de prudence donc je laisse à côté
par contre la justice donne envie
d'avoir de l'élégance pour défendre des
idées et la justice permet d'être plus
prudent mais pour une autre globalité
humaines pour nous préserver
mutuellement est derrière moi la sagesse
la sagesse viendra quand j'aurai les les
années de mon grand père peut-être ou de
yourcenar
mais là juste pour moi c'est une ligne
de mire et elles sont oubliées on l'aura
bien compris merci merci infiniment
fatou diop d'avoir été avec nous dans ce
rendez vous sur public sénat merci d'un
regard merci infiniment se retrouve très
vite sur public sénat
[Musique]